Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Lali. Ich bin Astin und heute für Sie ist zustande. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Rudolf Pool.
Rudolf? Rudolf. Rudolf.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vorname bestätigen?
Ja, Rudolf.
Nachnamen ist Pool oder ich hab Pool.
Ich heiße OHL.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57.
Am 16. Mai 1967.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin groß 1,82 Meter.
Ich wiege so 1,89 kg.
Was fühlt Sie uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit Tagen ganz heftigen Husken.
Da kommt ganz viel Schleim raus.
Ich habe fast keine Luft mehr bekommen.
Ich musste schnell atmen.
Heute Nacht habe ich schlecht geschlafen und habe geschwitzt.
Dann habe ich Fieber gemessen.
Ich hatte 39 Temperaturen.
Mit der Brustkoffee.
Ich fühle mich richtig krank.
Ich habe gedacht, ich komme gleich zu Ihnen.
Seit wann haben Sie...
Der Husken ist schon ein paar Tage.
Aber dass es mir so schlecht geht,
das ist erst seit gestern Abend.
Aber Husken tue ich schon seit 5 Tagen.
Seit gestern ist es in einem schlechten Geburt.
Ich habe keine Luft bekommen.
Ich habe solche Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe alles weh gemacht.
Kopfschmerzen ist das auch seit gestern?
Ja, das ist jetzt so.
Es hängt vielleicht mit dem Fieber zusammen.
Fieber haben Sie gestern gemessen?
Ja, da hatte ich 39 gestern Abend.
Hatten Sie etwas genutzt?
Nein, ich habe noch nichts eingehauen.
Ich hatte auch gar nichts zu Hause.
Ich habe das nicht.
Ich kenne gar nicht, dass ich so hoch fühle.
Willkommen Sie gerade Luft?
Gut würde ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen Luftnot.
Ich muss schnell atmen und ständig Husken.
Vielleicht können wir Ihre Werte kontrollieren
und dann das Gespräch weiter machen.
Welche Werte meinen Sie?
Wir müssen wieder viel Temperatur,
Körpertemperatur und sowasch das Set-Guns kontrollieren.
Vielleicht brauchen Sie auch sehr leichte Stoffe.
Vielleicht brauchen Sie sehr leichte Stoffe.
Jetzt können wir weiter machen.
Wie stark sind Ihre Kopfschmerzen?
Ich habe eine Dröhnenbärne.
Diese typische, wenn man sich nicht gut fühlt,
kann ich nicht einschätzen.
Wo genau?
Hier vorne im Sternbereich.
Sie haben auch Brustkopfschmerzen?
Ja, beim Husken tut mir alles weh.
Ist das auch stark?
Das ist wegen Husken.
Das ist schon ungewöhnlich.
Ich kenne das schon,
wenn man lange andere Husken hat.
Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl,
dass mir der ganze Brustkopfschmerz tut.
Hast du das,
habe ich Schweiß für Sie?
Das ist ein bisschen Husken,
aber so etwas wie jetzt, kann ich das nicht.
Sie haben auch Nachts Schweiß?
Ja, ich habe Nachts, habe ich ganz doll geschwitzt.
Ich habe dann auch schlecht geschlafen.
Haben Sie wegen Gesetze schon mal beim Arsch?
Nein, ich habe gedacht, der Husken geht alleine wieder weg.
Aber es ist nicht.
Dann bin ich direkt hergekommen,
weil es mir so schlecht geht.
Haben Sie auch Sie dann noch andere Bescheid?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wichtig ist,
aber heute Morgen hatte ich mit einmal Nasenbluten.
Ein bisschen Schnupfelnase habe ich schon auch.
Aber auffällig war,
dass ich Nasenbluten hatte.
Ich habe nicht mehr mit Nasenbluten geschlafen.
Aber das hat sich zum Glück wiedergelegt.
Sie haben auch Ausruf?
Wie sieht das aus?
Ja, das ist so ganz grün gelbliches Zeug.
Leiten Sie an,
irgendwie schon Erkrankungen?
Was eigentlich bekannt ist bei mir,
dass ich seit fünf Jahren schon,
dass ich Begegt habe,
unter Haustürs,
vor fünf Wochen hatte ich mal eine starke Attacke,
dass ich in einem großen Zeug solche Schmerzen hatte.
Dann gibt es eben noch eine Sache.
Aber das hat mit dem Husten gar nichts zu tun.
Dass ich so eine Hautveränderung habe an der Schläfe.
Da muss ich aufpassen,
dass ich da keine Sorge habe.
Ich habe keine Sorge,
ich muss eine Mütze mit Schirm tragen.
Ich trage da auch eine Salbe auf,
damit das geschützt wird.
Wir haben Hautveränderung.
Was haben Sie?
Eine Hautveränderung.
An der Schläfe.
Das ist aber nur ein
Sonne.
Dass das reagiert.
Dann trage ich da so eine Salbe auf.
Ich muss das immer ein bisschen beschützen vor Sonne.
Dass ich mich nicht so direkt in der Sonne bewege.
Sie haben noch etwas gesagt,
aber ich habe akustisch nicht verstanden.
Seit fünf Jahren haben Sie Gicht?
Ja, genau.
Vor fünf Wochen hatte ich eine heftige Attacke.
Dass ich Schmerzen hatte.
Ich hatte einen starken Attack.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig
irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Was ich nehme,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es gegen die Gicht ist.
Es ist das Zylorik.
Ich nehme morgens eine.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Wie gesagt,
nur noch im Sommer dieses
Gehehl für die Schläfe, für die Haut.
Dann muss ich,
das ist vielleicht auch noch wichtig,
ich habe so eine
Intolackung.
Ich habe eine Intolackung.
Ich habe eine Intoleranz
über Laktose.
Deswegen muss ich hin und wieder
ein Laktasepräparat nehmen.
Hilft das?
Eigentlich hilft mir das ganz gut,
aber ich versuche jetzt,
ein bisschen Laktose zu meiden.
Wir haben Laktas.
Da bekomme ich Blähungen
und Bauchschmerzen.
Haben Sie andere Alleygien?
Ja,
ich habe einen starken Auslag bekommen,
als ich Amoxicillin bekommen habe.
Das darf ich also nicht bekommen.
Haben Sie noch andere Alleygien?
Ne, sonst nicht.
Sieht sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, das hängt natürlich mit meiner Arbeit zusammen.
Ich hatte mal ein Kapatschummi-Operation.
Wissen Sie, ich arbeite als Florist.
Und da macht man halt sehr viel mit den Händen.
Und man schneidet eben viel und man braucht viel Kraft in der Hand.
Und da habe ich das wohl ein bisschen überlastet.
Was machen Sie, wer du fliegt?
Ich bin Florist.
Ich arbeite mit Blumen.
Okay.
Ja, Sie schneiden oft und deswegen hat sie sich gerade bei sich.
Noch andere Operationen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das war eigentlich das einzige Mal, dass ich operiert worden bin.
Okay, lieber, haben wir schon geflüchtet.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genug?
Ich habe mich jetzt nicht ständig gewogen, aber ich glaube mein Gewicht ist stabil.
Wie ist er ab und zu?
Normalerweise ist es nicht gut.
Aber jetzt die letzten Tage habe ich nicht gut essen können.
Also da ging es mir nicht gut genug.
Können Sie flach schlafen?
Normalerweise schon, aber ich jetzt natürlich gerade nicht.
Ich bin nicht froh, wenn ich überhaupt schlafe.
Also ich muss inzwischen durch mich aufsetzen, auf die Bettkante setzen und abhusten und ausspucken.
Und ja, es ist scheuselig.
Haben Sie Beschwerden oder Verrentilungen bei dem Wasser lassen?
Wer merkt?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgack?
Ja, also im Rahmen dieser Laktoseintoleranz, wenn ich da mal nicht aufpasse, dann habe ich halt starke Blähungen und auch Durchfälle mal.
Aber eigentlich mit dem Laktasepräparat geht das ganz gut.
Wachen Sie?
Ja, zurzeit zwar gerade nicht.
Das schmeckt, weiß Gott nicht.
Aber ich rauche schon seit vielen Jahren und ja, aber auch nicht so viel.
Ich rauche in zwei Tagen ein Päckchen.
Also es ist wirklich nicht so richtig starke Rauche, aber eben schon jahrelang, ja.
Seit wann brauchen Sie?
Wie viele? Ja, seit ich 19 bin, ja.
Okay.
Sie denken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, nicht direkt.
Also ich trinke jeden Abend eine Flasche Bier, ja.
Und wenn es mal zu feiern geht auch mal ein bisschen mehr, aber also regelmäßig eine Flasche Bier am Abend.
Haben oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit anderen Drogen?
Mit Drogen, nein, mit Drogen, zum Glück nicht.
Ja.
Wie bin ihr älteren noch?
Ja, mein Vater ist schon früh gestorben, der hatte eine Staublunge und meine Mutter,
die hatte jetzt, im hohen Alter, die hatte so Verwachsungen im Darmbereich und hatte dann eine Operation.
Aber das hat sie zum Glück überstanden, aber das war, da ging es ja schon ziemlich schlecht.
Und da ist sie jetzt noch dabei, sich zu erholen.
Okay, aber ihr Vater ist gestorben, ja?
Mein Vater ist gestorben, ja.
Im wäsche Alter?
Ja, der war Anfang 70.
70?
30 oder 72, er hatte eine Staublunge.
Hab ich das nicht verschraubt?
Er hat im Bergwerke arbeitet und hatte halt eine ganz verdreckte Lunge, kann man sagen.
Weg und Lunge.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, Geschwester habe ich nicht, war ein solcher Kind.
Okay, wenn sie verheiratet.
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder, die sind aber ja jetzt schon ziemlich groß,
sie sind zwar noch alle im Haus, aber also alle aus dem Kinderalter raus eigentlich.
Okay.
Sind sie gesund?
Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Okay.
Ich glaube, das waren das meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, eigentlich, was ich jetzt natürlich wissen will,
was wir gegen den Husten machen können und warum das mit einmal so schlimm ist.
Ja, ich habe Impfungen nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie noch eine Frage?
Haben Sie alle Impfungen?
Was für alle?
Impfungen und Impfungen.
Alle Impfungen.
Zu viel, ich weiß ja, also ich bin ja wegen der Tabletten eigentlich regelmäßig
bei meinem Haus aus und ich meine, dass ich also zum Beispiel Corona bin,
ich geimpft ja.
Jetzt für dieses Jahr noch nicht, aber im letzten Jahr hatte ich meine Impfungen
und Grippelimpfungen habe ich auch mitgemacht, immer.
Okay.
Weiter.
Aufklärung.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt ja gefragt, was kann man tun und sagen Sie mir jetzt
noch, also was, wie es weitergeht, Frau Dr. Lahle?
Herr Puhl, ich untersuche sie erst,
danach möchte ich Blut abnehmen.
Aus Blut schauen wir ihre Entzündeparameter
und vielleicht brauchen wir auch noch Röntgenbild aus Brust.
Röntgenbild der Brust, okay.
Ja, genau.
Dann sprechen wir nochmal, wenn die,
okay, das ist, okay, gut.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Aber eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Also, haben Sie eine Corona-Test-Frage gemacht?
Ja, habe ich gemacht, vorgestern habe ich den gemacht, der war negativ.
Negativ, okay.
Und haben Sie eine Corona-Test-Frage gemacht?
Ja, das macht, der war negativ.
Negativ, okay.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit, also bevor diese Beschwerden
anfangen haben, haben Sie Kontakt mit jemanden,
die erhält und selbst umgehalten haben?
Na ja, im Geschäft hat man natürlich immer wieder Kontakt
mit Leuten und ja auch naturgemäß ist es immer ein bisschen
freut bei uns im Geschäft.
Ja, also weil wir es nicht so warm haben, damit die Pflanzen besser
halten, ja.
Und vielleicht bin ich deswegen so erkältet.
Noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Schön.
Also, Herr Paul, haben Sie Geruchs oder Geschmackverlust?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Also ein bisschen verstopfte Nase habe ich, aber ich kann noch
riechen und schmecken und ja, ja, doch, das geht noch.
Ja, also Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie gestern
einen Corona-Test gemacht haben.
Ja.
Also, wie war die vorgestern, sorry.
Also, war es positiv oder negativ?
Der war negativ, der war negativ, natürlich.
Ja, dann hätte ich das gleich gesagt.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja, das war auch witzig.
Sie hat gefragt, wie stark sind denn die Schmerzen?
Sie haben aber nicht die Skala angeboten.
Ja, nicht.
Er kommt natürlich ein Patient vor, der sich nicht
auf die Schmerzen schmürt, aber er hat sich nicht auf die
Schmerzen geschmürt.
Ja, aber ich habe es auch gesagt, dass ich nicht auf die
Schmerzen schmürt, aber ich habe es auch gesagt,
ich habe es auch gesagt, ich habe es auch gesagt,
ich habe es mir auch gesagt, dass ich nicht auf die Schmerzen
schmürt.
Ja, nicht.
Er kommt natürlich ein Patient von alleine nicht darauf.
Ja.
Also, die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Und was haben Sie noch gesagt, Schmerzqualität,
oder?
Bundesschmerzen und Kopfschmerzen beschreiben können Sie.
Beschreiben.
Ja, also Kopfschmerzen habe ich so ein bisschen beschrieben.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe so dröhnen, Kopfdröhnen,
Also so ein drückenden Schmerz kann man das vielleicht nennen und die
Torachschmerzen würde ich vielleicht als brennend und drückend beschreiben.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt.
Frau Gerhild, können wir Arsatzkischee anfangen?
Ja, wir sehen uns immer.
Okay, bitte schön.
Guten Abend Frau Oberjassin.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen Patienten vorstellen, den gerade eben gesehen habe.
Ja, wir waren es ja.
Herr Rudolf Pol, 57 Jahre alt,
stets ich vor mit seit fünf Tagen bestehenden Kost mit grün-gelbiger Sput.
Und seit gestern Abend Fieber und Düsbner.
Also, der Patienten über Kopchmerzen, Torachachschmerzen und einmalige Heute Morgen NASA-Bolutung.
Wie heißt das?
Epistax.
Okay, ja.
Wie hoch war denn das, Fieber?
Nun 30.
Wann hat er das gemessen?
Gestern Abend.
Ah, ja, okay, gut.
Was hat er noch?
Gestern konnte er nicht gut schlafen wegen dieser Dispne.
Sein Kopchmerzen ist drückend und vorne.
Frontal.
Frontal, ja, genau.
Und Torachschmerzen sind brennend.
Er hat gar keine Torachschmerzen und das streiten nicht aus.
Er hat keine Gerucht und Schmack.
Gerucht und Geschmackverlust.
Geschmackstörung.
Bei den Vorerkrankungen, er kann ein Gehichts seit fünf Jahren.
Sagst du mal, die Fachbegriff?
Atritis yurica.
Atritis yurica, ja.
Und er nimmt, ich kenne diese Windkante auch nicht sehr gut,
zooloric.
Morgen ist eine.
Und er hat auch ein, wie ist das, Fachbegriff.
Ich weiß nicht, Hautveränderung in Schlafen,
aber er braucht nur Sonne-Schutz.
Okay, und was noch?
Er hat Lattusintoleranz.
Wir können Sonnenallergie oder Fragerhalt.
Könnte man sagen, ja, also es ist nicht explizit beschrieben,
ob es eine Sonnenallergie ist.
Ist die Hautveränderung bei so einem besterlosen Schlefenbereich?
Er hat Lattusintoleranz und beiden allergien bekannt amoxicil allergie.
Er reagiert mit auch Hautausflug.
Grusitis.
Biden Opis hat ein Carpentonal,
Zendronen des Regents, wo der operiert,
für fünf Jahre.
Seit wann hab ich nicht gefreut.
Begrüßt, wenn ich an einem Neese habe,
ich bin schon erzeitlich.
Er hat kein Problem beim Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang.
Er ist ein Raucher.
Ich muss rechnen.
Ungefähr 80 Packungsjahr.
Ja, das passt so sehr.
Er trinkt regelmäßig ein Flasche Bier.
Und bei den Familienanamnese.
Eine Flasche Bier am Tag, oder wie?
Genau.
Sein Vater, bei den Familienanamnese,
hat sein Mutter, Liebnis.
Aber sie hat ein Samm-Opie.
Er hat wegen Verwechslung.
Erwachslung?
Sein Vater ist mit 72 Jahren Versturbe.
Er ist wegen Pneuma.
Er ist ein Konioser.
Aber am besten ist Antrokosa.
Er ist ein Polarist.
Er ist als Beruf und verheiratet mit drei Erwachsene Kinder.
Die Kinder sind auch gesund.
Und?
Auf der Symptomatik besteht der Veldach auf eine Pynomonie.
Was könnte das Alternativ sein?
Differenzial diagnostisch?
Differenzial diagnostisch kann auch ein akut myocardial Infakt sein.
Das ist ein Fakt, vielleicht ein Torachsweiß, deswegen habe ich das gedacht.
Und das ist...
Denken Sie mal alle, das ist Zeit.
Ich könnte auch COPD zum Beispiel.
Ach so, das wäre auch noch ein möglicher Job.
Ein Griffeinfektion, vielleicht.
Influenter, ne? Ja, genau.
Gut, ja, was machen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Es ist früh noch für Grippe, Grippeinfektion.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten, diagnostisch?
Ich muss erst untersuchen.
Ach, wo ist auch...
Was erwarten Sie?
Ja, kann ich Rassingeräusche abhörchen?
Ja, ich muss das beachten.
Und Laborsch kann ich...
Ne, machen Sie mal auch noch weiter bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Okay, was Sie praktisch auskultatorisch machen.
Oder abhörchen.
Was erwarten Sie außer den Rassingeräuschen?
Außer den musst du beachten.
Weil der Expressions...
Bitte?
Sag es noch mal.
Kann der tief einatmen und ausatmen?
Ja, ich verstehe.
Dann kann der Patient tief einatmen und ausatmen.
Inspiration, Expression.
Ja, kann er das?
Oder muss er so atmen?
Er ist kursatmisch.
Ja, ja.
Und...
Was bedeutet Frau Leile?
Ta-Shubna.
Ja, genau.
Gut.
Er kann halt den Großkopf nicht so weit anheben.
Sondern das ist alles nur ganz schwach in der Exkursion.
Gut. Und wenn Sie klopfen...
Aha.
Klopfschein?
Ein Hüft?
Wie sagt man das?
Wahrscheinlich 3. Semester oder so.
Haben Sie bestimmt gelernt?
Genau, aber...
Klopfschein ist gedämpft, ne?
Gedämpft.
Ja, das erwarten Sie.
Was machen Sie denn weiter für Untersuchungen?
Als Labo.
Bestimme, lasse ich...
Blutbild, 1-Zunde-Parameter.
Wahrscheinlich...
Erhöchte als 1-Zunde-Parameter.
Wahrscheinlich sind die erholt, genau.
Und das lassen Sie noch untersuchen?
Ja, vielleicht kann ich auch Heizensohne.
Ja, gut.
Und das lassen Sie noch untersuchen?
Der Patient hustet...
Ah, ich sput und untersuchen kann auch.
Genau.
Ne, dass wir unter Umständen einen Erreger haben.
Was machen Sie denn noch?
Weiter für eine Untersuchung.
Eine technische Untersuchung.
Als Bildgebung mache ich als Tolax Blöntgenbild.
Blöntgenbild Tolax.
Haben Sie da auch eine Erwartung, was Ihre Radiologen da finden?
Ja, wenn der Patient ein Phänomen hat, kann man Infiltration sehen.
Gut.
Wenn Sie Ihre Annahme bestätigt, was wäre denn die Therapie?
Welche Schritte würden Sie machen?
Geht er wieder nach Hause oder nehmen Sie ihn auf?
Ich glaube, er muss in den Köckner ausbleiben.
Ja, das ist doch schon mal etwas.
Und dann?
Dann braucht es wahrscheinlich Sauerstoff, Antibiotik und Anagessika.
Ich glaube, Parankalage.
Ja, also, was braucht er dafür?
Ich lege einen Zugang.
Wenn man wenig zu einem, also gute Zugänge legen, dann kriegt er seinen Antibiotikum.
Was kriegt er noch für Medikamente?
Anagessika.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Er hustet.
Antibiose, Schmerzmittel.
Was kriegt er noch?
Ich habe im Chat gesehen, in Halleiste.
Ja, also, ein Mokolitikum würde man auch noch geben.
Ja, ATC, nicht ASS, oder?
ATC.
Ja, genau.
Und gegebenenfalls Sauerstoff.
Okay, dann untersuchen Sie mal den Herrn Pol weiter und halten mich auf dem laufenden,
das bei den Laborergebnissen und bei, vor allen Dingen auch bei der Röntgen auch,
eine Aufnahme rausgekommen ist.
Ja?
Okay.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Ja, wir hatten ein bisschen Probleme, glaube ich, mit der Verbindung.
Ja.
Zum Teil, weil die Kommunikation einfach gestört.
Aber Sie haben schon gemerkt, dass es ein ziemlicher Unterschied war.
Die Anamneseaufnahme war super.
Ja, war, also ja auch, sprachlich glaube ich, kein Problem.
Und auch inhaltlich ziemlich eindeutig.
Bei der Wiedergabe haben Sie sich ein bisschen schwergetan.
Ist Ihnen wahrscheinlich selber auch aufgefallen, dass es nicht so richtig flüssig war.
Vielleicht habe ich es ja auch wirklich gänzlich mit der Pneumonie.
Nun gänzlich auch im Fall die Fuse rischt.
Ja.
Das ist ja eigentlich so etwas, ja, wo ich denke, das gehört so ganz früh in die Diagnostik.
Ja, vor allen Dingen glaube ich ja auch in der gerontologischen Medizin,
wie viele Leute sterben letztendlich analog mit Entzündungen.
Ja, insofern ist es eigentlich so ein Basic-Ding,
wo Sie wahrscheinlich schon tausendmal irgendwas drüber gelesen haben.
Und ja, das war jetzt vielleicht sogar so einfach,
dass Sie gar nicht auf die Ideen gekommen sind.
Aber Sie haben die Diagnose ja richtig gestellt.
Aber wie gesagt, die Darstellung, das war ein bisschen mühsam.
Sprachlich, wenn da so ganz große Probleme waren,
habe ich es eigentlich immer gleich kontrolliert.
Bei dem Kapaltunnel bin ich mir gar nicht sicher,
ob Sie überhaupt nicht Jahreszahl gesagt haben, ob Sie überhaupt gefragt haben.
Die fünf haben Sie, glaube ich, irgendwie aus dem Hut gezaubert.
Ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Ich habe sie nur geschrieben und ich dachte, das ist fünf danach.
Aber ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Ich hätte Ihnen sagen können, dass es vor 13 Jahren war.
Jedenfalls wäre da auch noch interessant, welche Seite rechts, links.
Wenn man schon fragt, okay, meistens ist es die Arbeitshand,
die rechte Hand, weil wir meistens rechts sind.
Gut, ja, was Sie gemerkt haben, was so ein bisschen fehlt, sind die Fachbegriffe.
Ich weiß nicht, wie scharf die Monsterana dahinterher sind.
Dr. Gündes ist da immer sehr oft gesagt?
Nach der Prüfung Mindestanz fünf Fachbegriffe gefragt.
Ach, die fragen auch noch Fachbegriffe nach.
Aber dann ist es natürlich gut, wenn Sie die Fachbegriffe schon vorher mal verwendet haben.
Das steigert die Chance, dass Sie Begriffe bekommen,
die etwas mit Ihrem Fall zu tun haben.
Und dass Sie die auch dann gut erklären können.
Ja, genau.
Zum Beispiel war einer dieser Fälle, wie nennt man diese, wie nennt man diese Gichtanfälle?
Wissen Sie das, wenn die Großzehn Grundgelenke, wie die tun?
Ich hab das gestern gesehen, aber jetzt...
Podagra.
Proudaube, genau, genau.
Ja, das haben die tatsächlich bei diesem Fall nachgefragt.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ich glaube, Sie haben gemerkt, wo die Schwachstellen sind.
Üben Sie noch ein bisschen dieses Arztgespräch.
Ja, vielleicht mit irgendeiner Kollegin,
Freund, Familie, irgendjemand, der da ist.
Und ich kann Ihnen nur anbieten, machen Sie einen schriftlichen Bericht,
den Sie mir schicken, den ich Ihnen korrigieren kann.
Das wäre auch noch eine Option.
Das ist vielleicht manchmal auch hilfreich, dass Sie praktisch ein Modell haben,
dass Sie dann flüssig vortragen, dass Sie das noch mal üben können.
Okay, danke.
Okay, gut.
Dann für heute war es das.